european countries have begun imposing
new restrictions on public
and private life as they struggle to
cope with steep rises
in coronavirus infections the uk which
has
europe's highest pandemic death toll has
unveiled a new three-tier system
closing pubs gyms and betting shops in
the highest risk areas
and the regional government in northern
ireland has just imposed europe's
harshest second wave lockdown
restrictions the czech republic already
imposed a state of emergency today
new restrictions come into place closing
all schools bars restaurants and clubs
and the netherlands is also returning to
partial lockdown closing restaurants
hotels and cafes for two weeks
it was what the hospitality industry was
dreading most
a return to lockdown from midnight
restaurants bars and cafes
in the netherlands must shut their doors
for four weeks
masks too will now be mandatory in
indoor public spaces
the government says it was left with
little choice in the face of spiraling
infection rates
it's a hard message and the new rules
are going to hurt
but it's the only way because the facts
don't lie we have to be stricter on
ourselves
and stricter on our behavior
it's a similar picture at the forefront
of europe's second
wave in the czech republic testing has
been ramped up across the country
and tighter measures have been enforced
as well as the leisure industries
schools will be shut for three weeks
masks at tram stops
now a must officials conceded they may
have relaxed rules too
quickly in the summer
i wasn't strong enough in the summer and
i didn't insist on measures to protect
us from the second wave
meanwhile in france business owners in
the capital threw a cocktail party
protest
to draw attention to their plight
bars are in the middle of a two-week
closure that officials hope would stem
the rising number of infections
it hasn't and the public is bracing for
new restrictions to be announced
the government needs to put in place
strong and powerful measures
in line with the economic tragedy that
we're facing here and across france
across europe growing infection rates
fresh lockdown measures
and the inevitable health and economic
hardship to follow
is the headache for which there are no
easy fixes
well for more let's bring in dw's band
reget he's following this story for us
in brussels bent
talk us through these european traffic
lights how's it supposed to work
the european traffic light has four
colors actually red
for dangerous zones orange for medium
infection rates and green
for countries and regions which are okay
and gray for those countries
who don't give the data to the ecdc the
european center of disease control in
stockholm that will publish
this new map of europe not only of the
countries but
the regions and this is new broken down
to 200 regions
and the new point is that not only the
incidences so the new infection
cases will be rated but also
the number of tests and the positive
tests that are returned so you have a
new criteria to
to apply and that might change the map
a little bit for example in germany the
number 50 incidences
is no longer valid it can arrange
between 25 to 150 incidences
but you also have to apply the positive
return rate of tests
which should hover around four percent
and not higher
and all these measures are designed only
for tourism travel
essential travel and urgent business
is not afflicted by this and all these
measures
are voluntarily so the member states are
not obliged to take part in this new
traffic light system okay well this
system does sound like it could provide
some valuable orientation to travelers
uh
how soon could it be put in place
but it could be in place actually next
week because the data are all there
and the ecdc the european center for
disease control will publish this
on the website reopen.europe.eu
and then everybody can see it but the
measures that follow out of this new map
these new indicators
are also up to the member states so they
can decide if they will put in place a
new lockdown
curfews or the obligation
to go into quarantine this is all up to
the member states
and while europe waits on that traffic
light scheme infection numbers continue
to rise
what are the main hot spots about right
now
well according to the newest numbers and
i have to look on this map
on the map here in my map it's um
western europe is mostly affected so
spain france
the united kingdom which are the current
hotspots also belgium here in brussels
but now check the czech republic on the
rise and also the netherlands again and
you can see
also a surge in bulgaria and romania
and according to this new traffic like
system only finland
and parts of eastern germany would be in
the green zone all the rest is orange or
red
and the tendency is that the cases are
going up
but in difference to the first wave
mortality hospitalization
and also excess mortality are fairly
lower
but the trend is upwards and now it's
the problem how to
to flatten the curve again most of
europe orange or red
bantry in brussels thanks so much
well the united kingdom has recorded
europe's highest pandemic
death toll and new infections there are
growing at an
alarming rate especially in the north of
england prime minister boris johnson has
outlined a three-tier system
reinstating restrictions in high-risk
areas dw charlotte chelsea pill reports
from liverpool and manchester
it's last orders for this pub in the
northern english city liverpool
after a three and a half month lock down
earlier this year pubs and bars here are
once again being told to close their
doors
new restrictions are coming into place
across the north of england bringing a
new wave of darkness for both businesses
and customers i got very depressed over
a shutdown and i've only started picking
up since books started opening again
i'll do that and see my friends have a
couple of beers
chill you know it's heartbreaking
it's a place to escape to if you like
you know apart a long time apart elaine
died in april
with this covered she had her health
issues
within two weeks she was gone i lived by
myself i
got depression and stuff so we've been
supporting each other
it does feel as though we're being
punished like many landlords here connor
foley says even paying rent will become
difficult
after days of uncertainty he thinks the
government in london's failing
businesses
in the north i think it's quite
disgraceful
how they've let people fear the worst
without
knowing what help they will get not even
speaking to local leaders until
the very last minute i think it's just a
horrible way
to govern in normal times never mind
when everyone's afraid of what happens
next
but there's no getting away from the
case numbers liverpool has one of the
highest covered rates in europe
alarmingly the uk now has more hospital
admissions than before it went into
lockdown in march
and it's inevitable other cities will
follow in liverpool's footsteps
before anybody enters the restaurant we
have a temperature gauge so we'll just
check your temperature
neighboring manchester award-winning
restaurant owner helen c is doing
everything she can
to keep her doors open but she's living
every day on a knife edge
i didn't know whether to order stock for
this week if i'm honest
um i didn't know whether to take
bookings
i didn't even know whether i should open
up or not you can't operate
when things are so uncertain you don't
know whether you're going to be open or
closed tomorrow
the lady in red is my grandmother lily
kwok
and she opened one of the first chinese
restaurants in manchester even helen and
her sisters are third generation
restauranteurs
they're now facing an unprecedented
challenge we're already struggling
if i'm honest it's not just me carrying
the burden it's the entire family
that's a lot of pressure and i don't
want to let them down i don't want to
let my customers down
and yet with the trading conditions
i might have no choice but with every um
you know order
we write them a little note we call them
lockdown letters
takeaway boxes are now one of just a few
rays of light for restauranteurs like
helen
we still have a whole lot of life to
live
and a whole lot of examples to set a
message of hope to a community holding
its breath
for more bad news
well those are just some of the latest
curbs
other measures are already in place in
several european countries
spain for example has a state of
emergency in the madrid region to
enforce a partial lockdown
affecting four and a half million people
masks are now
mandatory in all public places france
has placed paris marseille
and seven other large cities under
maximum virus alert
closing bars gyms swimming pools and
banning public parties
cases are also rising rapidly here in
germany since friday
new nightlife restrictions are in effect
in the capital berlin bars must close at
11
p.m further hitting berlin's famously
liberal nightlife
economy chancellor angela merkel will
meet leaders of germany's federal states
shortly
to try to solve the confusion around 16
different
sets of rules the
incidence of new coronavirus cases in
germany keeps rising
every day new cities join the list of
risk areas
some areas in germany have surpassed the
key threshold of 50 infections per 100
000 inhabitants over the last seven days
including major cities such as frankfurt
berlin
munich and cologne as infections climb
germany is trying to figure out how to
deal with the new upsurge
one problem the solutions differ all
over the country
in berlin for example there are no
limitations for travelers from
inner german risk areas staying in
hotels
there is also no obligation to wear
masks on the streets
another city another set of rules in
munich
travelers from designated risk areas can
only stay at a hotel
if they show a recent negative covet
test and masks are mandatory in some
outdoor areas of the city
the different rules are making it hard
for germans to understand what they can
and cannot do
in essence no one can really remember
the rules
they seem to be pointless and i don't
think they will survive for a long
period of time because
more and more cities are going beyond
the threshold which is
let's say the thresholds the alarm
threshold which is in use here
so the policy becomes redundant in a
couple of weeks anyway
but the end of that chaos might be near
the leaders of germany's 16 federal
states arrived in berlin
and are set to meet with chancellor
angela merkel for the first non-virtual
meeting in
months some state premiers have already
announced they will cling to the
accommodation ban
while others want to see it dropped the
question
is will the chancellor's personal and
in-person authority
be enough to unify the positions
i want to put that question to our chief
political correspondent linda crane
milinda can the chancellor
wrangle unified measures from all those
16 regional leaders i think it's quite
likely
that she can she's known as an adept
negotiator and it will definitely make a
difference
that the state premiers are meeting
personally with her
for the first time in a number of months
and there is
precedent uh for broken brokering such
an agreement if we look back to the
first wave of corona here in germany
in mid-march april there was quite a bit
of uh discrepancy and differences of
opinion
among the different federal states but
under the watchful eye of the chancellor
at that time
they did manage to agree on a unified
approach and the fact is there's
increasing recognition
that the lack of consistency this
patchwork of different
rules does confuse citizens and
therefore
discourage compliance so today we're
hearing from two of the most powerful
state premiers the heads of north
rhine-westphalia on the one hand
and bavaria on the other whose
approaches often
differ that they do now think it is time
for a unified set of rules well
infection rates are rising rapidly
really across the country are we going
to see a unified approach with tighter
restrictions then
yes i think that we will see tighter
restrictions for example
in regard to the wearing of masks
perhaps
extending the number of locations where
masks must
be worn perhaps also some tighter limits
on
public gatherings and and social
events but that might be paired with at
least a partial roll back
on controversial measures whose efficacy
has been questioned by authorities and
that would certainly include
this travel ban that has been imposed by
some rural parts of germany on
people coming from hot spots from bigger
cities
requiring them to show a negative corona
test
before being allowed to stay in local
hotels
authorities say that that doesn't make
sense especially with testing capacity
increasingly limited melinda germany
came
out of phase one of this pandemic
looking rather good how is it looking
for phase two
well people here are definitely in
agreement that
this is a decisive moment for the
country both the government spokesman
saying
earlier this week that germany is at the
beginning of a second
wave and that this now is a crucial
moment in time
and the head of germany's uh leading uh
corona
virus institute the the public
health authority of robert koch
institute says as well that this moment
is decisive and what really counts is
individual responsibility across the
board so we'll see if that
responsibility starts now with this
meeting of the state premiers our chief
political correspondent
melinda crane thank you melinda
you